philippe pilate au bonjour vous êtes le
responsable de l'ansej beau golf
national golf national qui va recevoir
l'open de france à partir du 3 juillet
du 3 au 6 juillet pour les gens comme ça
qui sont toutes là dedans school qui est
aussi le golf de la fédération c'est la
fois je pense une fierté un challenge
dans de recevoir une compétition comme
ça bonjour pas free soient effectivement
c'est vraiment une fierté de recevoir ce
tournoi qui est le plus vieux tournoi
d'europe continentale et
un challenge parce que effectivement
chaque année c'est un tournoi qui avec
l'objectif de la ryder cup en 2018
en plus en plus regardées prendre de
plus en plus d'importance et on a des
joueurs de voilà les meilleurs mondiaux
qui maintenant viennent battre le fer
sur le sur le magnifique parcours de
l'albatros oui c'est un challenge aussi
parce qu'il faut que le parcours soit
parfait le parcours effectivement c'est
vrai que le cahier des charges pour
pouvoir accueillir un tournoi de cette
importance est vraiment très très chargé
et effectivement c'est un travail qui
commence mais une fois le tournoi
terminé cette année le 7 juillet en gros
avait on va commencer à préparer le
tournoi de l'année prochaine donc
effectivement c'est un travail de longue
haleine un travail permanent des équipes
du terrain que je salue pourrait pour
leur courage ce niveau là parce qu'en
plus vous dire que dans l'année vous
recevez des golfeurs enfin ddd voilà des
amateurs qui vient de jouer ici donc
voilà il faut quand même le préparer ma
crise n'a pas effacé pas faire mais je
veux dire effectivement après c'est un
parcours en tant que gold de la
fédération nous sommes dans un golf
public donc ouvert à tous les licenciés
de france et on va dire de navarre est
effectivement focant sutton sans
capacité de proposer une qualité de
parcours à l'identique tout au long de
l'année parce que les gens qui viennent
jouer albatros vient de jouer le
parcours de l'open de france dames donc
on se doit de proposer un parcours de
qualité douze mois sur douze
effectivement et vous parlez on va
revenir l'open de france à une seconde
et parler de la ryder cup qui aura lieu
en 2018 est-ce qu'il ya déjà dédé des
gens qui sont attirés par sa qui
viennent de l'étranger
ça va monter en puissance évidemment
mais déjà on a de plus en plus de
joueurs étrangers qui viennent on voit
la clientèle qui s'internationalise avec
beaucoup de joueurs outre manche outre
atlantique et qui maintenant regarder
viennent au golf national parce que
c'est le site de la ryder cup 2018 et
c'est un sujet sur lequel on travaille
qu'on va essayer de développer bien
c'est énormément à l'international pour
montrer qu'en france et à paris mais il
ya aussi le golf national à proximité de
paris où on a un joyau à côté la
capitale effectivement guy versailles en
plus on va voir voilà c'est très bien
placé et s'éteint c'est un des plus
beaux golfs
d'europe classé voit oui exactement on
est classé dans les meilleurs golfs
européen on est classé aussi
effectivement dans les meilleurs golfs
mondiaux et deux par là là on va dire la
visibilité pendant l'open de france 2
par également la qualité du parcours qui
est proposé pendant l'open de france il
est vrai que c'est un parcours qui est
maintenant mondialement connue oui tout
à fait alors là on est demandé au départ
du 1 enfin pas autorisé au départ doit
avancer un design typé on voit qu'à
voilà un gars étaient des difficultés de
ce golf cesser les obstacles d'eau qu'il
est partout dix ans peut-être pas pour
les produits à bas mot près disons que
même pour un les obstacles sont en jeu
donc effectivement il ya c'est un
parcours qui a été dessiné réellement
pour pour accueillir ce tournoi et à
l'open de france donc c'est un parcours
qui est assez on va dire qui est très
très bien dessiné tous les trous sont
comme on dit dans le golfe sont très
challenging est effectivement ben voilà
tout ce qui est placée tout ce qui est
mise en place les obstacles au dos quand
on peut voir c'est quelque chose qui
rend un parcours qui rend le parcours
acier on va dire assez difficile et il
n'y a pas il n'y a pas de coup on peut
se reposer et en même temps les les
joueurs les grands joueurs l'adorent 1
mais les adore le parcours parce qu'en
fait c'est un parcours qui est comme ils
le disent qu'ils aient faire c'est à
dire que c'est un parcours qui va
récompenser réellement le meilleur
numéro 2 voilà le meilleur joueur de la
semaine serkis est vrai qu'il est
pénalisant pour celui qui sera à moins
en forme sur la semaine du tournoi mais
pendant le tournoi celui qui on a
vraiment produit le meilleur golf sera
récompensé parce que c'est pas un
parcours où ou la chance peut peut aider
peut aider le vainqueur dont la vous
parliez tout à l'heure du plateau c'est
à dire des joueurs qui vont venir là
encore c'est une l'affiché
cette année oui on a une affiche
fabuleuse on a donc en joueurs français
on a vu que thor dubuisson allait placer
la vie il ya un très bon joueur français
enfin il ya toujours eu d'abord aux
français mais là il y en a qui explose
doit on à victor dubuisson effectivement
qui est parmi les miens les 20 meilleurs
joueurs mondiaux nong ce qui est
exceptionnel pour nous pour le golf
français on à alexander levy également
qui a gagné un tournoi récemment sur le
sur l'european tour et après derrière on
a mcdowell qui est parmi les meilleurs
le tome 2 litres qui est le tenant du
titre qui va venir voilà défendre son
titre et le récent vainqueur de l'us
open donc martin gamer joueurs
l'allemand voilà l'allemand qbg10 les
haïtiens ce qui a déjà gagné oui
effectivement il avait gagné
je croise en quatre ans voilà trois
quatre ans sur le sujet voilà donc c'est
ça c'est des joueurs qui ont gagné dès
qu'on appelle les tournois majeurs et
cap tournant majeur est effectivement
mcdowell et puis et puis gamer en gagner
ce sont des tournois majeurs ce sont des
ans veut dire des réguliers également de
l'équipe de ryder cup donc ce sont les
parmi les meilleurs joueurs du monde
mais ils sont dans l'est dans les dix
premiers donc extrêmement on va avoir un
plateau exceptionnel cette année oui
alors pour pour les autres voilà qui
connaissent pas il faudra compter que ça
se passe sur quatre jours du jeudi au
dimanche oui il ya combien de combien de
participants au départ en fait alors en
nombre de participants est à peu près
c'est un peu plus de 150 joueurs qui
montrent qu'ils vont venir et qui
arriveront donc ils vont débuter jeudi
matin le non-droit donc et donc les 150
joueurs vont jouer deux premiers tours
donc le jeudi et le vendredi et leur
envoyer la moitié qui disparaît voilà et
le vendredi soir il ya ce qu'on appelle
un code donc on coupe et on prend les 70
premiers ex-aequo qui eux vont continuer
à jouer le samedi et le dimanche pour ab
pour pour gagner remporté remporté la
coupe oui tout à fait oui alors
peut-être bien une chose aux gens qui
veut qui veulent venir c'est que on
parlait de gamer emparé de mcdowell mais
tous les joueurs qui viennent ici sont
des jouets avec cette nouvelle quand on
peut suivre aussi peut-être parfois
facilement des joueurs moins connus et
prendre un plaisir fou loi ben disons
qu'en fait pour jouer pour jouer à ce
niveau là s'il ya un lien que des
joueurs exceptionnels il ya que de très
très très bon joueur après comme dans
tous les sports il ya des joueurs voilà
qui sont un peu au-dessus du lot mais il
n'empêche que effectivement pour le
golfeur avertis ou même non averti ce
qui est intéressant c'est de suivre un
petit peu tous les joueurs parce que ils
ont tous un niveau de jeu exceptionnel
en plus derrière il va y avoir donc vous
avez des joueurs français en tant que
tournoi français beaucoup joueurs
français que l'on être présent donc on
compte sur les français pour venir
supporter on va dire la colonie
française mais après derrière il ya
effectivement tout le monde et avoir eu
tout à fait vous êtes professionnel
céline ont
aimé et méchoui et pouvoir le jouer j'ai
pas le niveau je n'ai pas la prétention
d'avoir d'avoir leur niveau et par
rapport à cela dont je suis enseignant
mais je n'aime pas le niveau pour
pouvoir jouer au niveau de ces joueurs
là oui alors un mot sur un sursaut de ce
golf national parce que c'est donc le
gros lot ce sera le colza la ryder cup
mais c'est aussi le voilà c'est le cas
des golfeurs français au fond c'est le
bluff des golfeurs français oui
effectivement c'est à dire qu'en tant
que golf de la fédération c'est
l'objectif de claude rouget quartiers
dits ciellement qu'il était le président
de fédération qui était à l'initiative
de la création de ce parcours là de ce
site c'était d'accueillir au moins
une fois tous les joueurs tous les
licenciés français dingo donc c'est
vraiment le golf de tous les licenciés
le golf de tous les français tout en
sachant que sur le site nous avons bien
évidemment le joyau qui est le parcours
de l'albatros il ya des arbres et en
dehors nous avons également un autre
parcours qui le parcours de l'aigle
qu'un parcours plus accessible qui est
moins challenging que celui ci et on a
également un parcours 9 trous qui est un
parcours école ou sur lequel on
perfectionne et ont fait découvrir le
golf au plus grand nombre effectivement
est-ce que des compétitions comme l'open
de france à dire dene des nouveaux
joueurs ben disons qu'en fait ça attire
parce que en complément de l'activité on
va dire du spectacle donné par les
joueurs il ya toute une série
d'activités et d'animations qui sont
proposées pendant les longs mois avec
des initiations animé par la pga france
qu'est l'association des golfeurs
français des professionnels français
donc on essaie de faire en sorte de
profiter du du tournoi pour que les non
golfeurs puissent découvrir l'activité
et se découvre une nouvelle passion au
travers du golfe rit et on voit lui sont
malheureusement il ya des français qui
peuvent y accède enfin au plus haut plus
haut niveau coiffe donc après derrière
on ad on a beaucoup de joueurs français
qu'il ya des travaux à des hackers
d'ailleurs ici qui poussent derrière on
a eu des vainqueurs on a eu jean
françois remesy si des fois on a deux
fois deux années consécutivement c'est
ce qui résume tout ce qui
je crois que c'est c'est eh oui c'est
intemporel initialement ça pouvait se
voir mais effectivement c'est
extrêmement rare on à thomas levet
également qui a gagné le tournoi donc
effectivement c'est un tournoi en tout
cas nous ce que l'on souhaite c'est
vraiment que cette année on est tous
derrière des joueurs effectivement comme
levi du buisson kiki voilà en rêvent de
les voir des soit reporté la coupe le
dimanche soir effectivement est ce que
quand on travaille comme vous le
stationnement 3 4 jours comme ça avant
le début des vêtements on est un peu
stressé ben toujours chaque année oui
chaque année c'est une remise en
question en gros c'est vrai qu' on est
nous sommes regardés c'est un tournoi
qui est qui et qui est diffusé à
l'international c'est un tournoi comme
je le disais tout à l'heure qui est
maintenant avec la ryder cup fait que
les grandes instances sont là et chaque
année le stress est là effectivement on
sait ce qu'on a à faire mais il ya
toujours un petit peu d'excitation dont
le sang dans les équipes effervescence
puisqu'elle est toujours bon parce que
c'est vrai que déjà nous ça nous permet
d'avoir une coupure pendant l'année ce
tournoi pour nous c'est vraiment c'est
vraiment la cerise nadal la semaine de
l'année alors on peut parler un peu des
quizz tout à l'heure on a vu passer 1
monsieur en voiture comme ça c'est
quelqu'un qui vérifie à la pour tous des
tournois européens c'est ça oui en fait
ce monsieur en fait c'est effectivement
le ailleurs le grand patron de des
intendants sur saint-andrews et
effectivement c'est un monsieur qui est
qui est en charge de vérifier que que le
parcours a été préparé suivant le cahier
des charges donné par l'european tour
tout en sachant que sur site nous avons
une équipe de jardiniers ultra complet
avec
super intendant la personne d'alexandre
reyes
qui fait un travail exceptionnel toute
l'année et on peut le voir là quand on
voit la qualité avec laquelle sur
laquelle les joueurs vont pouvoir jouer
c'est c'est vraiment excellent ça peut
être pas l'ennemi de votre ennemi ça
peut être la météo ouais le seul ennemi
ce que l'on craint c'est l'orage l'orage
l'orage qui nous oblige à couper parce
que c'est la seule voie la réalité mais
trop de météorites qui peut interrompre
voilà exactement sous l'orage parce que
c'est dangereux voilà et puis le
brouillard comme on a pu avoir quelques
années où le matin on avait un peu de
brume donc empêcher le jeu mais sinon
c'est l'orage après derrière le parcours
a été préparé de telle façon que même en
cas que ce soit 1 puis le parcours
devrait devrait absorber les quantités
d'eau que ce soit à la fois dans les
bunkers à la fois sur les surfaces de
jeu tels que les greens et sur les
fairways et je pense que au lendemain de
l'open mardi à des eaux qui vaut mieux
effectivement donc il ya le lundi il ya
il ya deux compétitions le lundi où en
fait les sont des amateurs qui vont
jouer et qu'ils vont jouer dans les
mêmes conditions à des joueurs mesurer
voilà
quatre jours voilà c'est bon pour c'est
bon pour nous et c'est bon pour l'équipe
l'enseignement et après on organise le
grand défi qui est un une compétition
qui va se dérouler
à partir du mardi où là effectivement
encore c'est une composition des
amateurs vont venir affronter affronter
l'albatros dans les mêmes conditions
avec les mêmes positions drapeaux les
mêmes marques de départ les mêmes
configurations refaire ouais enfin voilà
tous pareils on n'a plus qu'à leur
souhaiter gros creux encourageant oui on
va le rct beaucoup de plaisir beaucoup
de courage vous avez un favori ouais
cette année cette année moi je joue et
victor dubuisson latinos hors jeu
français voilà je suis français je
supporte en tant que lui sans quelques
ratés qui a déçu il
ya encore quatre ans veut pas de
participer à la dette de la ryder cup
ben on le souhaite au et de tout fait en
tout cas ce qu'assure qui ce qui
laissera cette année et puis et puis on
souhaite de tout coeur que ce soit un
des français à la ryder cup 2018 oui
tout à fait merci beaucoup merci brigato
merci beaucoup patrice